in the lobby of financial peace Plaza
right here in Martha's place
Jackie is with us hey Jackie how are you
hey Dave what's up oh you know I'm here
to do my debt-free scream that'll work
where do you live I'm st. Louis Oh fun
very cool well it's good to have you how
much dad have you paid off
I'm 70,000 70,000 bucks yeah how long
did that take you twenty six months way
to go
making what kind of money I started out
in the low 40s and then I went up to
hire like low 90s whoa
nothing like doubling your income in two
years what'd you do did you double your
income in two years
um I mean basically I had started out
like kind of at the bottom of in my
industry I'm doing what I was doing and
so I kind of knew that eventually my
income would take off but I mean I just
worked really really hard and yeah and
most people don't and so you got noticed
correct correct
yeah that's pretty cool yeah very good I
love it what do you do for a living I do
pharmaceutical sales ah yeah you got a
good gig yes and nine he's not the top
you're not done yet
no no you'll probably get to double that
if you got a good gig yes very good good
for you so that helps blow through
seventy thousand bucks in twenty six
months what kind of debt was that what
did you buy it was fifty five thousand
was student loans and then the other was
a car and credit cards so what made you
decide you needed to get out of debt
could get out of debt and that this
would work and put you on this journey
26 months ago well Dave um I had
actually started college and decided
that I had two choices I could take out
student loans or I could cashflow it and
I decided I'd rather just take out the
student loans and my plan was to go
through school and then the next two
years after I graduated I lived with my
parents and then not got the student
loans I mean kind of start my life there
I didn't really want to cut out the
vacations and the shopping and the
parties and all that stuff so that was
my original plan when I graduated that
didn't happen and so I had a difficult
time getting a job when I first
graduated
I lost my job a couple times and so a
friend of mine had actually given me
your book I recommended your book about
a year after I graduated I'd listened to
it and I'd said well I don't think this
is for me right now that'd be a good
future plan and so that a couple years
later after getting up going through a
couple layoffs I decided well I think
I'll do this right now
so yeah I listen to it again in January
2012 and then I just got intense so it
sounds like you've been out of school
about four years five years five years
yeah and really I'm sorry six years six
years and really about four of those
years kind of sucked yes yes really
sucks yeah I think it's kind of you know
it's a good thing for people maybe that
just graduated 20 minutes ago that are
the economy's been yeah she went through
four years of suck and now she's killing
it yes yes awesome yes well worth it
very good good for you very good so
you're single I take it yes so what do
you tell people the key is to getting
out of that um I think for me it was
more like a mindset change I kind of
always used money well in the beginning
I used money when I was growing up to
kind of buy things that my parents
couldn't buy me and then as I got older
when my income would grow but also I had
more needs then they weren't taking care
of I use debt to kind of leverage that
that difference so yeah that I mean so I
think the key for me was just changing
that mindset that my income is this much
I have to live within that and if I need
a new bag or you know anything I can't
get it unless the money's there
so that I mean that took a while for me
to get I mean probably the first year I
had to really get that in my brain yeah
that is hard what is the me shift in
your whole way of viewing money is hard
one just drive by that that's a big deal
yes but what when you started this you
thought was gonna be really hard but it
ended up actually being little easier
than you thought it would be I mean just
timing everybody else's is the budget I
mean I really thought I'm like oh my
well my first budget I sat down and I
had $150 left over for the month for
groceries entertainment gas etc yeah it
sounds like oh my god why did I decide
to do this
now I have to face the reality it was
really depressing so I think honestly it
was the budget just sticking
to that and it was such a freeing
feeling because even though yeah I had
no money left over I knew now instead of
just kind of using my credit card and
yeah yeah being ignorant basically okay
yeah it makes you face it but it turned
out to be easier than you thought that
part of it yes yes yes good deal
well congratulations Jackie thank you
very much of you way to go you really
have you've really done a big deal here
because most people can't even pay off
seventy thousand ever and you did it in
26 months as a single person saying I'm
gonna I'm gonna I'm gonna step on this
I'm not gonna let this control the rest
of my life and I'm gonna well it's kind
of about growing up really at the end of
day you know congratulations well done
hey can I say one more thing you can't
okay well I will say I called into your
alright I was listening your show
religiously on a daily basis and a girl
called in over the summer and she was
making like what I was making and she's
like you know David seems like every
time every month I come back and I've
overspent on my entertainment budget and
that same thing was happening to me all
summer and she was spending exactly what
I was spending 150 bucks a month is what
she was giving herself and you said why
don't you give herself some more money
you make good money and I thought so I
went back and I added it in and it was
like what I needed because I kept going
over and so it's kinda started scourge
me because I'm thinking you're not
you're not intense anymore like you're
not you know even have the gazelle
intensity you're losing focus but that's
all it was a simple adjustment and I was
back on track so thank you good but the
principle with that is and it's a great
thing to bring up for folks listening is
that your budget needs to reflect
reality cracked and sometimes you have
to change your view of reality because
some people's reality is not really
reality but once you've done that you
know it really does need to you know you
can budget $100 a month for food but
you're not gonna make it so your budget
needs to reflect really what life looks
like and if you can do that then you can
afford you you're emotionally stay
encouraged and can stay with it which is
what you were saying yes that's very
cool yes all right Jackie from st. Louis
70,000 dollars paid off in 26 months
making 40 now making 90 oh and the sky's
the limit count it down let's hear a
debt-free screen okay three two one
love it
Oh way to go it's fun that's fun you can
tell when somebody's paid a price to win
way to go very well done
you